[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
yo what's up all right yeah i don't know
what happened like you muted
did you mute i was muted too man i was
muted too
there was no volume what's going you
guys
this is addict we're here with the attic
show i'm here with
forte you know we got some good topics
for you some good information going down
man
uh sooner or later bg will be here if bg
does get here sometimes you know how bg
is
he gets left or right pulling all sorts
of different way
and he sometimes forgets stuff but he
the invite has been sent
whatever he shows up he shows up so uh
let's go ahead and uh you know first off
forte
because i forgot to do it because you
know clearly we messed up i messed up
not you
i'll take full responsibility forte what
have you been doing what have you been
playing
oh man uh not playing return oh
because i refuse to uh have my
my progress wiped every time i die
or not die i don't care about dying but
because of things that are unforeseen in
the game
that might have some stuff to do with a
system or it might just be the
incompetency of
a developer but i actually like house
marks i'm gonna give them a pass but
outside of
the little bit i did play of that um i
did go in and play
um some re8 um actually really really
cool
um tried to play a little bit destiny
today but we already know how day one
destiny is when it comes to a new season
yeah
it's kind of crazy not playing you're
basically not playing
it's kind of crazy how many years have
went by and they still haven't been up
and they still
every every it's like i'm not any kind
of like networker or anything like that
but
one would think by now you would have
some form of solution
well did you did you hear that the
supposedly cross play got activated
today that's why they're having issues
oh well see that see stuff like that
makes sense but
when you do that that's the only thing i
can give them because it's a regular
season
update forte cross plate wasn't supposed
to come out till next season though so
somebody jumped the gun at bungie
like a whole season early so it's always
like don't hit this button
i'm gonna hit this button
they said don't hit this button even if
you're color blind this button's red if
it looks
red purple if it looks uh anything close
like it could
be inside the red family don't push that
button and they push somebody push the
button
yeah that's that's definitely what
happened but you know outside of that
man just
oh man just getting caught up on a lot
of um
fps boost games and stuff i've been
playing a lot of battlefield playing a
lot of um
titanfall 2. i'm actually working on a
video for um
fps boost and uh i know because people
been getting on me about videos for a
while so that's the one i've been
working on but yeah i just been enjoying
a lot of those fps boost games and
just enjoying 120 frames per second man
you know
and shout out to um ea and bioware for
giving
mass effect legendary edition 120 frames
per second at 1440p
and i am the first person that will
always tell people that frame rate
matters
more than resolution and 1440p is a
perfect resolution
frame rate matters but i do feel like if
that resolution
isn't at least at a good point for the
first
it devalues the whole game too so well
it depends on the game if we're talking
about can i know you got to think about
you know a lot of those original those
old xbox one games like battlefield
being the 720p
and um the original titanfall running at
what
900 p or something like that i i
i do get that but it's like
as long as i don't see that in newer
games that's what i
that's the thing that i would have a
problem with like i don't want to see
120 frames per second and you know
900p in a brand new game that comes out
i don't want to see something like that
but when it comes to like the older
games and stuff
that's fine um but this just shows me
one thing
though the promise of the future it's
like
games that run at you know 1800 p
and 60 frames per second now because
they can't hit that um
they can't hit that um that 4k mark
who's not to say that with this
um with this new ability for them to go
in and you know they already showed that
they could do
resolution boost they've shown that they
could do fps boost
who's not to say that in the next
iteration of whatever xbox or
playstation comes out or
you know a playstation never does
anything like this that we don't get
games that were like something like
destiny
at 4k one 4k uh 60 frames per second
who's not to say when the next system
comes out that that doesn't get boosted
to 4k
120 you know because there's they shown
the opacity to say that we can actually
do this without the developers
even have to do anything so i'm looking
more at
this is just the this is more of the
the under layer to the whole situation
they're like
yo this is something that's going to be
here not just now
but the games that you're playing right
now at 4k 160
you technically could probably be
playing those games at 4k 120 when the
next system comes out
and i think that is the thing that's the
promise of fps boost to me so i'm super
excited just to
see what this actually turns into later
on in that generation towards the next
one
i feel like when it comes to the boost
thing i feel like a lot of people like
to downplay
and i don't i never understood why you
want to downplay something like that
because
to me when it comes to the boost it's
like look like
they are insuring and giving people you
know a lot of reinsurance like look if
you invest into this company
we're always gonna have you're always
gonna have that game you're never gonna
get to a point
and to me we're consumers we we should
want that
like even if you don't play old games at
all
you should want the ability to always
have your games no matter where you go
and you know especially microsoft's
taking it to the next level without like
work where xcloud's starting to get
starting to be popping we know we're
still improving that
what's that is where they want it to be
because i personally feel like xcloud
was designed for 5gs but it works with
four g's
and um i feel like once five
g's is is a regular thing where everyone
has it
and you know everyone's clearly been
taken over by zombies and stuff because
all this stuff with five g's is crazy
people people
people say it gets cancer but that's
besides the point
once everyone got access to 5gs i have a
feeling gaming is going to be more
portable than it ever has
and then you're finally going to have
nintendo actually have competition in
the portable market
yeah i think that's the that's the move
right there you know
um nintendo in that portable market is
pretty strong though and um
i think the only thing that's going to
knock them off that square is if
everybody decides to just want to play
on her phone more and
as of right now people aren't ready to
give up their
dedicated hardware for to go as much as
people say
you know they don't have space to carry
all the stuff around
people find a way to carry a switch with
them and uh
i think that is the perfect form factor
for portability on the go um
it's even more portable than a laptop
and a lot of people like to take their
gaming laptops and stuff with them
if we can ever get a point where xbox
can get um
game pass on to the switch like i know
they want to
then you're going to see a whole nother
level of engagement with that system too
so phones is the future but i think as
of right now nintendo has carved himself
out of very nice
nice place to live when it comes to
portability
so do you think out of curiosity do you
think that if the portable scenario
becomes
so demanding with the streaming and it
grows
do you think that you know we'll start
playing way more games outside of your
crib than you play inside
like because because to me i feel like
it the the natural home environment is
always going to be key
but i do feel like depending on how
we go in the direction that the
industry's going there will be times
where you're gonna be sitting the
doctor's office you can be
you gonna be playing fortnite apex
legends just chilling waiting for your
your appointment to have happen
like and i think it's gonna it's gonna
feel the same it does
on that phone than it does at home yeah
i don't think you're gonna see it
anytime soon
like that rash transformation to that
because
we're still doing what our generation
where when we get out the house we ain't
trying to do nothing but
you know bg he can speak to this when he
gets here too you know
when you walk out your house you really
ain't trying to play games unless you're
you just sit like you said you're
sitting at the dmv or you're waiting for
your doctor's appointment
most of the time you're driving but you
know the the youth that's coming up now
you know they're looking at it more as
shoe i'm at the butt i'm taking the bus
um and you gotta think the youth the
people that's like my brother's
generation and lower they're the ones
playing these games on the go anyway
so that's where you'll see the
transformation happening you'll see
more people like that as you know the
people that are like
15 to 20 you know them growing up the
ones that are used to
carrying their laptop and stuff with
them or they're used to having to switch
on the
on the train you know most of the people
that are over in age southwest asia and
japan
and stuff like that that play nothing
but portability you know
once uh sooner or later that type of
gamer is going to creep out
over here and be very prominent and not
saying that console game is going to
suffer from it because i don't think
it's truly going to really suffer for it
but i do think mobile gaming and the
direction that microsoft wants to go
with their whole platform being
everywhere you can be
to play that's going to be the new
barometer when it comes to
people playing games on the go i don't
think it's going to be as foreign to
people
in the next 10 to 15 years yeah
and i think you know especially us we
we have a huge fear in terms of
streaming you know we yeah
we and it's because it's not really
necessarily our fault
we've had some of the worst examples of
streaming uh and i think up until stadia
and you know x cloud to a point
like we've never seen and the kind of
experience that's like yo
maybe this is actually a valid thing
that you can do in the future
yeah definitely yo we got uh we got a
five dollar super chat from
crazy horse shout out to you brother he
says bungie said
f you sony i'm turning on cross play and
we're not paying that crossfade
p listen man bloody y'all here tripping
right now
they whoever did what they did today
man you you just met you just ruined a
lot of people's day
like today like launch day for a destiny
dlc people take days off
work for that yeah and you know what's
sad and i was going to get to your super
chat here in a second or forte
definitely
uh got it before me i appreciate that
forte but you
you know what the crazy part is is like
us is destiny fans and i know bg is
about to be here he's getting stuff
ready in the background
shout out to bg for coming in here
straight pretty much right after he got
off work
but uh so he took his tie off yet yeah
so
the the crazy part is we have been used
to this so much
that forte's off work and he still
didn't try to log in their day
right when it first came out no i i went
out to i went up
i went out to lunch with my mom
got some hibachi i was sitting i was
still sitting in the chair at the time
the reset happened i was like yeah this
ain't going to be working so
there's no reason for me to rush home
and i get home and it's
better yet i logged in i did the update
and it let me in the tower but guess
what for the whole last three hours
nobody was able to get into the tower to
help so
your boy you know i learned i learned my
lesson a long time ago about destiny and
day one dlc launches
yeah so okay let's go ahead and uh get
into the show a little bit
you know one of the things i want to
talk to and i and i made sure that bg
was here because i know he's a huge
person on the other
aisle than i am is right now i feel like
there's an internal debate
low-key because of sony like we can't we
can't act like that doesn't happen
is first-person aspect versus
third-person aspect
you know you got your games like fallout
you know prop most likely star filled
which you know a lot of these games have
the option to switch back and forth
between them uh you know
besides stuff like cyberpunk you know
you couldn't switch to third person
unless you got on a vehicle
and then you got you know stuff like
pretty much anything sony makes god of
war
uh it so i what i want to ask
the people in this chat and the people
in the chat itself
is what is your preference in terms of
do you like first person over third
person and if you do like one of them
over the other
why so i'm going to let you guys in the
chat go ahead and put that in the chat
and forte let's start with you because
bg's still doing
uh you know still getting home doing bg
things so
what is your favorite and why um
my favorite oh man it's kind of weird
because
we all know what mass effect plays that
you know mass effect is a third person
game and it's
pretty amazing and um shout out to the
new one the
the legendary edition is coming out on
friday
but i still will always fall in that um
first person um market when it comes to
those type of games
but it also definitely comes down to the
type of games that we're playing if
we're talking about
shooters like games like uh far cry
or games like um destiny or call of duty
titanfall stuff like that i always like
the
um intimacy of just seeing the weapon on
the
on the screen uh and being able to see
just what's in front of me it's more of
that tunnel vision it's like i don't
need to see
everything that's going on around me
because
all i'm trying to do is focus it on
what's in my peripheral vision and
what's in front of me
and uh i think once you add the element
of a character
on the screen that's when you take away
from that type of gameplay like gears
award i think
does it very very well um
but it's also about the style and you
know of the characters they want you and
then it's a cover game too so when you
like cover involved i always got to
shoot you always got to go third person
i think i get what you're saying from
that but like to me i feel like
is it like means like all third persons
play like yo
there's some that you know i don't feel
like besides stuff like the witcher 3
they all have like an in-depth and game
play it's like you cover you shoot then
they have the stealth mechanics that's
in these third persons
but like that's pretty much all like
you know when you get first person those
are the ones that generally have like
the massive rpgs
you've had first persons that's been
platformers
like uh like the mirror's edge like
obviously third third person does a lot
maybe it's just because i grew up on the
fallouts on the other scrolls skyrims
and that's probably why i normally
gravitate more towards those type of
games
uh i do understand i will agree bg has a
huge saying when it comes to
he feels like a third person play tells
a story better
and i i do absolutely i do i do agree to
a point on that because i do feel like
third persons could tell a story better
but i do
i kind of feel like first person could
do it just as well depending on who's
developing the game
like france yeah type like francis i
know a lot of people didn't like
cyberpunk
but would not necessarily didn't like
the game they didn't like all the issues
that the game was having
but if you play cyberpunk i feel like
when you're
playing it and you're getting into like
the seats and you're opening
like it's very immersive like they did
their best to make the first person as
immersive as possible
so i feel like i get it some people like
the third person
some people like me like both of them
but i do prefer to lean more towards
first person
do you agree that if the
if the viewpoint is wrong that that
should be right there enough
not to play the game at all even try
because you don't like the view person
it's not first person
no i mean i think you should definitely
try because i mean
i've always been first person over third
person and
i think like i said my favorite
game of all time is mass effect 2 and
that game is a third person game
i would have never experienced that game
if i didn't try
um to even see what it was like so guys
y'all hear me
yeah i can hear you so yo so i think
overall it's it's like i said it depends
on the game
like for me i do think the story aspect
is told
very very well it's easier to do in a
third person game it's not too
it's not saying you can't do it in the
first person but i also think in a third
person game
um especially a game like cyberpunk
where you you got to show off the way
that your character looks and everything
you know all the awkward
changes and stuff like that which you
know that they don't let you see your
character and they don't let you see
your character
that i don't agree with that that's the
thing that i hate
about first person when they have
all of these unlockables that you're
supposed to have on your character but
you
never see your character i think out
writers does a really good job of that
when it actually works you get to see
the gear that your character has on in
it um
it's more of a showpiece and it's part
of the game and i think stuff like that
you know the only game i can really
think of first person wise that does a
good
job of portraying that is probably
destiny because of the third person
aspect that they give you
when you're in like you know certain
areas of the game and everything where
they force you with the third imagine
and you can see that imagine doing a
third person
and uh a first person aspect with the
sword in destiny
i did that you can force it you can
actually force the game to do it it's a
it's a glitch in the game where you can
force it to play third person it's weird
as hell
that'd be interesting so we gotta weird
yeah we gotta i do think though that
it just depends on the game but i wanna
hear what bg got to say about it so
so real quick we gotta find out super
seven but jw is a shell
i love that name i don't know why but
it's just so funny
i'm gonna be honest unless it's a horror
game i prefer third person that uh
there's something about seeing your
character especially when you have
customization
involved i agree but but to me i feel
like a lot of third-person games don't
have customization
name me five
like visually like deep deep
customization
in person games you mean they're just
like their character aesthetic or like
the actual gameplay
no the character aesthetic oh uh that
changes how they look
uh oh you know i got bad memory i know
horizon did it
um there's definitely games that
that do it i mean if they're like if
they have rpg elements
i'll definitely do it then i would say
most i think assassin's creed does a
good job at it
and then and then i'll be seeing third
persons do it but then during the cut
scenes you're like default skin
like if that makes no sense but you know
let's
let's bg i brought you in for this topic
because i know you're a very passionate
person about this
uh when i talk about those the stands
that only like third person you one of
the people that come in mind because
you you ride and die for this viewpoint
and it's not just you a lot of people
love this and i i do feel like sony has
a lot to do with that because
they've made such wonderful games in
that third person aspect
right now bg obviously you like first uh
third person over first person
explain why that is i mean
it just ultimately it gives you
more possibility more room for for
certain things i mean
first person really limits a lot of
things it the first person
it cuts you off from a lot of things
from honestly it's really hard to make
uh like uh be fully immersed and make a
connection with a character when all you
see is floating arms
like the the performance that for one
like the voice actor has to give in
order to do that they have to go above
and beyond like
one of the few like an example of that
is uh
is is booker and bioshock infinite yeah
i feel like
we were able to connect with that
character but it's mainly because of
of what's the name's performance um you
know his name is step on my mind we know
who played them there's only two people
in the gaming industry who do voice
acting nowadays
um so if if his performance
wasn't there we would have like real no
really no connection
with with booker also i just feel like
it's it like first person has this like
sometimes this robotic feel to
it it's in it and it's like it's a lot
more entertaining to see
your character you know what i'm saying
like it feels more real your character
feels like
it's actually there more than just more
than just floating arms that's all i
really feel and and see when i play a
first person game it's just floating
arms
okay so let me ask you a question real
quick gotta find out super chat from
crazy horse
third person only i get several
headaches when
i try to play first person game it's
like i said there's a lot of people
you know i respect you guys is there any
first person games that you put that you
wouldn't have normally played but it was
in the aspect but you liked the game
uh so much that you know you liked the
idea of it you tried it and you ended up
liking like i
for me like dude the dx uh the du x what
are what's that game pronounced
deus ex dex like i love that game
and that's one of the reasons that uh uh
i feel like
they take real good uh advantage of a
first person aspect
yeah it did it well going in and out of
it but like
i feel i feel like you can take most
here's the thing you can take most
first-person games right
i believe this and put them in third
person and it would still work well
you can't do the reverse you can't take
a lot of third-person games and put them
in first person it'll work
it doesn't because third person just
allows you to do more
you know especially gameplay wise and
mechanically like things work in third
person but they
but they won't necessarily work in first
now
we were talking about something before
you came in here bg well let's talk
about the competitive aspect of third
person
because to me and forte we've been
playing destiny we we've played
that competitive aspect uh we what what
is it called
forte when people use the emotes to peek
around
yeah so so do you think you could be
more
do you think as a competitive scene
do you think it's better to be in the
first person genre or the third person
genre
i think third person absolutely takes
more more skill the the the skill
ceiling for third person is absolutely
higher because
in mo in most first-person games right
the main thing you really have to worry
about is aim and accuracy
in third-person games competitively they
also like movement is a huge part of it
you look at most third-person games
competitive
movement is huge like gears what like
one of the most important things in
gears is movement
online if you don't have movement you're
dead uh
uncharted same thing your movement has
to be on on on point
like strafing left or right and all that
stuff most first-person
shooters you don't really have to worry
worry about that that's not
that's not really a big factor in it so
there's a lot more things you just have
to worry about if you're playing a
third-person game
competitively i don't know i i have to
push you back a little bit that just
just a little bit because
like i feel like first person is because
it's it's a lot easier to to to really
like
you know kind of cheese it a little bit
in third person when you're able to
to look around that corner and see
what's around that corner you're nowhere
near the edge of that wall
like i i feel like you you like we said
corner peaking like
right now in destiny bg's just so you
know what we're referring to destiny's
clearly a first person shooter
so what people are doing is they're
going around like trials of osiris
they're
they're going around like a sniping
corner and instead of peeking their head
over there
they're doing an emote that pops into
third person
and then they peek around the corner so
like to me
scenarios like that maybe it's okay if
it's all first person or all third
person
but the fact that you're able to hit
that third person
aspect in destiny is such an issue right
now that
death that bungie's gonna disable it for
competitive
uh v modes are they not forte if i
remember correct yeah they are
yeah because that's how bad it is
because it's kind of easier if you could
look around the corner and see that dude
there and he doesn't even know you're
there
obviously if you're playing the third
person homeboy at the other side should
be doing the same thing
so to me i feel like if you can see
around the corner you're not even around
the corner
that makes it a lot less more
competitive than it is
where you have to pop your head around
that corner and put yourself in danger
to actually get the kill but in third
person you can look before you go
yeah uh yeah i mean that that's a factor
you mean like yeah
head you know just the whole head glitch
you know that that exploit
can be used in in you know even even in
third person games you know but it's
definitely worse
it's definitely worse than first person
because that's not something that you're
actually supposed to be doing um you
know by the parameters of the game i've
seen what you would use
you know i've seen that the uh destiny
videos doing that though you know how
bad it was i remember
because this has been a thing for years
i remember playing the origin
assassin's creed brotherhood the the
multiplayer they used to have
i love that assassin's creed multiplayer
they they don't really do it anymore
but i remember like what i would do is
you could you could
you could um whatever it's called where
you're peeking
because you're naturally third person i
remember looking around the corner
seeing people act different because
in that game i don't know if did any of
you play those
hell no like the whole point is that was
a thing
yeah well assassin's creed used to have
a multiplayer and the whole point of the
multiplayer
was to pick out the people that weren't
the
the npcs so everyone had the same npc
walking around with different npcs
and what you would do is you would blend
in with the nbc's
and the the thing that you do as the
attackers you would
decipher who isn't an npc
so you what you do is you like you know
i got to the point where you could tell
who it is if people are too close to
each other
because that's not how npcs gather
around uh
you could corner peek around like a
corner where they can't see you
and you can see them moving around like
bg i used to be so mean on this game i
used to
to find out who they were when i was the
um when i was the defender
and then i would run i wouldn't even run
very far run around the corner
tilt my camera to where i could see him
chasing me and the moment he came around
the camera
i'd punch him out and then keep running
like because he knew
that was an issue back then so clearly
it could be an issue now
and and like forte i kid you not he
didn't even know it was coming till he
went around the corner
because i saw him he couldn't see me and
it all happens is i just
i hit him and i ran every time i
sometimes i would do it eight times in a
row and then they would just stop coming
after me in general
so you know so do you think that
uh any type of first-person action
adventure games
uh bg so you you honestly don't like do
you not like the competitive scene in
first person
or that's that's what i want to ask him
because you know i know bg
been watching him ever since you know
the kill zone days
you know when this man was posting game
play for killzone
double doubles and stuff all the
freaking time um he was a beast back
dude
you know you're still the beast you know
the funny thing is he was really good at
that so that's what that's kind of gets
me because i know he's also a socom fan
too so i know he kind of goes both
ways on it so and you treat both of them
the same when you were playing on bg you
know you're very competitive in both
uh but you don't lean either you still
lean towards the third
um person way like so kind that you did
even when you were playing uh killzone
uh yeah i mean kill zone like if if if i
had a choice
like if you gave me like a choice of
like oh
you could make killzone like a natural
third-person shooter right now i'm
absolutely
still taking the third person shooter
the only probably the only game
that i would not change out of first
person is battlefield battlefield is
perfect how it is
oh it's perfect the way it is i agree
100
100 agree with that so
what's funny is bg like the biggest
competitive games in the first person
market that i've seen
you don't even play rainbow six siege
i'll i think you you you definitely duck
that uh
you don't want you don't want nothing to
do you didn't duck it
i didn't like the game you don't want
nothing to do with the smoking trials of
osiris
you don't want nothing to do with that
he he said destiny was garbage the day
he played it
like trials of osiris is some of the
most sweaty competitive
multiplayer i've ever played in my whole
life i watched bg
play when he used to post destiny gay
play like
eons ago i'm not like he's
like bg how how that is is it's it's 3v3
and when you kill each other you could
your teammates can revive you
but every time you die your your
duration how long you have to wait to
get revived
goes up and plus like it gets to the
point
where people like because now in destiny
at the top they show you who has supers
and who doesn't have supers
so like it's a little bit better than
the the reason because i know you don't
like it because of the the supers you
don't like people i'm ready
to shoot you with golden gods i yeah i
don't believe
i don't believe in games that like
that's the when i played i don't know
what's changed now are there still
supers where you could essentially kill
somebody in one hit
yeah you you you don't that's garbage
he doesn't like the he doesn't like he
never did like he he said that a while
ago i never liked the one
kill the advantage the only
way you should be able to one hit
somebody in a video game is a sniper
shot to the head that's it if you could
just pull out some magical
power and pow you're dead game's garbage
i'm not doing
the thing especially if everybody can do
it they've gotten a lot better and stuff
like that
like they have like sound cues that's
like really loud like
now well they had it in the first one
but now it's really loud in destiny like
you'll be sitting there
you'll hear golden guns look at no one
even uses golden gun anymore that's the
funny thing but
you're hearing it yesterday you'll hear
go to god and then
everyone it's like it's straight panic
mode bg go to go go to gun run run run
like man i get it you don't like that
stuff but you know i don't want to doom
in here too long i don't want to keep
you too long bg because i know you got
uh
your stream to do it so when it comes to
it
i think we can all agree choice is best
give us the choice that plays both uh
you know just like gta did
they they it was third person and they
switched to first person
uh one of the the mods get that dude up
out of here straight band him i don't
care
he he gonna put some stuff like that
straight back uh we got a two dollar
superstar from everborn what's good
gentlemen um
m-h-g-a i don't know what that is
make halo great again do you know what
mhga is
uh no just put that just put that in the
uh
he's oh he said make halo great again
that's that's what it is oh may kayla
great yeah okay yeah yeah
so you know if you want bg we could talk
about that real quick for you leave halo
because i know you're a big fan of halo
yeah
uh-huh right uh
did you bg we played halo 5 for hours
first did you just forsaken halo
i like halo's multiplayer uh i do that's
that's another that's another one
that's the part to me that well that's
another game i actually wouldn't change
the
the camera angle the only thing with
halo's camera is the fov i've always
thought the fov was terrible but that's
but the camera angle is fine for halo
oh yeah 105 at least so all right let's
set this up man because this is
i feel like we're all passionate about
this even even bg bg can
try to cap all he wants see he how many
hours you got in halo 5
bg i can look that up oh i have no idea
you could check yeah so i mean
we we're all passionate about this yeah
i just don't care about halo's story
like that the multiplayer i care about
iris don't really care about the story
so what i want to ask you guys is
obviously last year
there was a lot of mixed reception to
going how the game looked i don't
did anyone have an issue with how the
game played how it looked like it played
or was it all just graphics because to
me
i at the at the time i didn't even
notice how the game looked i was just
looking how it was playing
i saw the game and i was like oh man
halo i mean the gameplay was fine
it was i mean they they could have kept
the whole grappling hook thing that kind
of looked weird but
you know if they iterate on it and make
it better okay it's another tool that
they add to the game
but man once you start seeing it
the the biggest thing with that that was
is the fact that they were talking about
most powerful system and then your
number one top of the cream
game that xbox was built on
has pop in and textures not there and
lighting was completely missing and you
know
come to find out you know we we find out
more and more information all the time
um especially over the last week that
you know they're developing the
engine at the same time as the game and
they went back and changed a lot of the
stuff that was happening in the game so
there's just a lot of stuff that's been
going on with the game in general
but the gameplay i always thought was
you know fire because
game that's the one thing that halo has
in spades but
it just wasn't a good look for what
everybody was expecting from the most
powerful console if you're gonna
use the moniker that our system is
you know the bees needs when it comes to
all that then you gotta showcase that
and i think you know everybody a lot of
people
even people that were even probably
quietly
hating that hey the halo probably wasn't
gonna be as good
i think even they were surprised that it
showed the way that it showed
so that's where most of it came from
yeah so let me get the super chat
look your mass effects foolishness forte
has showed up on here now
like i can't i cannot wait to this mass
effect thing's over and this
this this legendary comes and goes and i
never have to hear this again
like bg let me tell you about the past
couple weeks for me
i'll be in i'll be in a party with these
people and all they talk about
is mass effect and then when they're not
talking about mass effect
they're arguing about mass effect i'd be
so glad when this is over
five dollars you should have played the
game just like we did
what i'm just talking yeah i'm talking
to the wrong person about mass effect i
think mass effect is garbage
so we got a five dollar super chat from
jd as a from j.w
is a shell is it okay to wear my
my bag hat in here i'm assuming he's
talking about uh
uh i don't know make make halo great
again isn't that the same
we're not gonna we're gonna move past
that uh make
add it great again come on man you guys
have been
clowning me for weeks to be clear mass
effect 2
is the goat for me oh my god man
look look i will
i do have to ask bg though what was it
the first one that turned you off and
you just
never the second you just never went to
go play the second one because you just
couldn't don't answer that because he's
going to turn this into a slander
it's an interesting question because
that's how i just that's why i really
just want to really want to know what it
was is that what it was the first one
just didn't get you
yeah i played the first one i thought it
was terrible then i just looked at the
second one and i'm like i don't think
this looks any better now he's going to
tell you
no they don't know let me let me let me
before taper
bg man that's just how that's just how
mass effect one is no that ain't like
like bg if you really want to give the
mass effect trilogy a start
just start with two guess what bg they
don't even care if you didn't play
number one
you could play two and they'll let you
start your own character and you can go
straight from two to three
what were you gonna say then forte what
were you going to say about that i was
going to say
you know what he absolutely right
because the first one was trash when it
came down
it took the see you see the biggest
difference between me and bg
bg said he ain't even look at the second
one i actually
looked at the second one and played the
first mission was like
yo i gotta carry my character forward so
i'm about to go struggle bus
through this first game so i can make
all my character progression go through
and that's the difference between me and
bg i actually went
i actually saw the game and when it
played it where bg was like
hell no i'm not doing this and that's
pretty much what i did
and i think you played all the
assassin's creeds right bg haven't you
uh
no no i've i played assassin's creed two
the the two after that and then pretty
uh i played up to four and then skipped
all of them after that pretty much okay
so you played basically through the
desmond series and then that was it
yeah see i'm the complete so his story
about mass effect is my exact story for
assassin's creed i refuse to play an
assassin's creed game because i never
played the first i played the first one
and hated it i was like what is this
game
and i never looked at the second one i
never looked at the third one
and i was like people keep saying well
it's a lot better now and i'm like uh
okay all right i just never wanted to
play it because the first one was so bad
so i kind i just got one thing to point
out forte
mass effect is not a title we're moving
on back to halo all right so
so bg since we're in place in space
though oh my god
since we're only gonna have you for like
another 15 minutes what would they need
to do in terms of multiplayer because i
know you're not really a big fan of the
single player you can briefly talk about
the single player
and why you don't really like the the
single player much anymore
but what do they need to do in terms of
multiplayer to win you back over to play
that regularly like you play something
like um what's that bad not bad company
um
road company are you talking about halo
yes uh
the multiplayer uh i i mean i really
like the multiplayer
of five so they don't really have to do
too much i mean listen
i'm okay with the the typical halo you
know multiplayer
formula i i i think i want the maps to
be
a little bit bigger i hated the super
like tight
you know super close corridor maps
you know i like them in some ways but
like they were the the maps were super
simplistic and corridor
and you know i hated the fov that you
know
a dude could literally be um on your
like like touching you on your left and
you can't even see him because the fov
is is so bad so yeah that they don't
really have to do much i think the halo
multiplayer formula is kind of
you know fine how it is and see i i i
know there's halo purists where
you know they argue whether oh should
running be in it should it not even be
in the game all that stuff i don't care
i don't care if it's in or not i can
play either way
y'all at all right i don't care what
have you considered
the core to halo multiplayer
uh two or three no like the core of
their multiplayer like how
features how it functions
uh i would i would say
it's it's really just about like the
the direct gun play um
that's that's really what it's about
it's it's about brs
um you know the pistols and
you know grenade placement it's about
the simple things honestly
really simple i think just
uh i think what's always made halo halo
is the map control
the fact that you uh i like what they
did in halo 5 where they started
announcing where
where the guns are and they started
announcing what stuff is coming up
they're like you got 15 seconds to a
sniper or something like that because
to me that's what's always been halo
it's been the fact that
if we don't get that shotgun they might
use that shotgun to win the fact that
everyone spawns
the same things the fact that you don't
have any loadouts
and i think that's why people didn't
like halo 4's multiplayer as much as
because
they kind of went away from that but in
halo 5 they brought it back
if you want the rocket launcher guess
what bud you gotta go get the rocket
launcher
and a lot of the time it means fighting
for the rocket launcher
yeah part of me feels like halo kind of
lost a little bit of his charm when they
started doing that though when it came
to announcing things
there was a there was a a secret skill
to halo 1 and halo 2 and halo 3 when
you just you had a person on your team
where everybody your team knew the
timers of everything
when they spawned it's like i kind of
missed that
and you're right they did jump the gun a
lot in halo 4 because they went that
whole kill streak
avenue and um that's when they really
started announcing like
orbital drops and stuff on maps and
stuff they tried to chase call of duty
when it came to that so that's why
i think that multiplayer kind of fell on
his face but i kind of missed
i'm not going to say they should get rid
of it but i do miss the fact that
yo when did we pick up sniper we picked
up sniper
you know once the sniper ran out we
picked it up you know
two minutes ago and we know it's on the
eight on it's on a three minute timer
i and you know and the teams that were
good
knew that stuff and you and when you
played against other teams that knew all
that stuff
it just took halo to a whole nother
level so
they they hold your hand a little bit
too much i think in in halo nowadays but
like bg said i do think halo guardians
um
their multiplayer was vastly superior
when it came to just the gameplay in the
movement because
that's the biggest thing that halo is is
it's all about movement it's about
positioning about
banking that grenade off that one corner
and knowing that there's more likely
somebody gonna be over there
halo's one of the few games still left
that a grenade is actually effective
oh yeah yeah you you use your grenades
to actually do stuff in halo
and part of me i hope they don't go too
far away from what halo 5 was i hope
they
keep it to the core how do you guys feel
about the grappling hook i saw some
people in the chat bringing up the
grappling hook
apparently you know i don't think you
can latch on to people but you can
actually like bring like coils and stuff
to you to throw it you can bring weapons
to you
i think that's gonna change a lot
because when someone's about to grab
that rocket launcher
and they're right there you just use the
grappling hook and yank it to you
i think that's going to be effective do
you think that's pretty close for that
though
do you think that's going to break the
immersion bg of like
grappling hook uh i think it's as
long as like the animation looks right
and they find the right way to implement
it into multiplayer
i think it could be fine i don't know i
don't know how it would be if you could
just grab people with the grappling hook
i thought it was
not maybe they should grab people i
don't think oh it's just for traversal
then yeah
i think you can you look i think you can
grab ai
like enemies on the uh like in the story
but i don't think you can grab
people in it okay in there but but they
i'm pretty sure that they actually came
out and confirmed that someone in the
chat
uh double double check that so you know
i honestly think when it comes to you
know
we we saw the bad thing that happened
with them last year
and you know they had to delay the game
a whole year do you think that
it's realistic that a year is enough
time to see
serious results or do you think we're
still going to
see uh a hail that we're going to be
disappointed with in
next month like we'll start with bg
i think you're going to see an optimize
a very optimized version
uh of what we probably already seen
um they're not i don't you know no i
don't think they're gonna be able to
change the game drastically because
uh i mean i think they're crunching
anyway i think they're gonna crunch for
this entire year
right um i don't think they have any
choice in that if they really want this
game to turn out
how they're envisioning it because you
know it's
you know they they got their v they're
being very ambitious about it
so i don't think it's going to be a
drastically different game i think it's
just going to be the best version
of what they are already shown all right
so let me ask you this
do you think uh first off let's go to
forte real quick uh
same question do you think that you know
we're going to expect a way better
product in terms of visualization on
that screen
this june that game's coming out in 2021
now right
yes no i don't think either i think
no i think it's going to be just like bg
i think it's going i think that game
like i and i said this on i think
because i was on the um
i was on the show with you guys when we
saw it for the first time and then i was
on there with you guys when we
when they delayed it and i said it then
i was like
unless they're delaying this game out of
2021
you're not getting a vastly different
game
now would it will you probably get
better feature sets will you
get a more polished version of the game
will that take care of the poppins and
stuff like that
does it give them another year to go in
and brush up on some of the texture
qualities and
do some 4k texture mappings inside the
game that probably wasn't there before
absolutely but when it comes to the
overall
fidelity of that game that game no that
game was sealed the moment that we saw
it
all we're gonna do is get a nice little
shiny coat of paint put over the top of
it
with some lighting because the lighting
looked terrible because
guess what there was none so we'll get
stuff like that but
overall i think what they said in that
um that article as of recently is the
fact that don't be blown away
well as soon as they said it was
actually coming out of 2021 i was like
well
i'm just hoping to have a good game at
this point i'm not really
looking for halo to do something that
halo hasn't done in
over a decade all right so here here's
my last question with the halo and then
we're gonna let bg go
let's say halo comes out i'm going to
give you two scenarios tell me
what your opinion of the outcome is for
both halo comes out
it's a great game no halo comes out and
it's an average game
or halo comes out and is straight up
straight up flop
like 60 mega critic which i don't think
i think the 60
metacritic halo gonna come out and get a
80 plus just for being halo that's just
my opinion like
i don't think halo is going to get
scrutinized too much unless it's like
a huge drastic change from halo from
that core halo thing
do you think that xbox will be
permanently damaged for the rest of the
generation
if x if if halo comes out and flops what
do you think
forte um if it comes
out okay we won't even talk about this
whole 80 i mean this whole 60 scenario
um if halo comes out and does what i
think it should do and it captivates
especially on the multiplayer side but
that's the part i care about
the most even though i do love the story
i just don't know
really what to expect from 343 when it
comes to story i just want to be
surprised when it comes to that and
if it's good it's good but the
multiplayer is the thing that's going to
keep me there and
if they can knock that out the park i
will tell you right now i will more than
likely quit playing destiny
all right so what about you bg do you
think that if halo comes out there
and it flops and i i mean flop where you
know
it it comes out buggy mess no one's
playing it you know
it goes around the same kind of i
wouldn't say as
bad as star not starfield as bad as
cyberpunk
but if this comes out and it's not like
an above
average game because i honestly feel
like people get this mixed up
if halo comes out and it's an average
game and people like it
that's not a flop it's just not what
microsoft needed i don't think that
turns the needle anywhere but if it
comes out and it's a flop i do think
that's going to hurt them a little bit
but i personally don't feel like that's
going to [ __ ] them what do you think
bg
and bg's gone so uh you went to go get
my bad my mic was muted i didn't know
okay uh
so if it comes out and um if let's say
it's an average game
right let's say like you know 80 you
know somewhere in the
low 80s mid 80s and you know you play
the game and it's and it feels like that
type of game
right i think then that that
then then that's when halo
has to just be accepted as just another
decent or good game it's no longer
what halo 2 and 3 was you know this
this amazing flagship title it's just
another good you know ip
under the xbox umbrella it doesn't have
you know it's it's not the the cream of
the crop anymore as far as microsoft ips
go
and which is you know that's kind of
fine you know you know every
you can't stay on top forever like it's
not it's not possible
with games like fortnite and warzone and
completely destroying that whole shooter
market it's hard to compete in that
market
yeah you can't remain the best ip
forever i mean
kind of the only the only ones that are
able to do it is like nintendo with
mario like
it doesn't matter how old mario get it
still seems to
people still still seem to buy it and it
still gets you know the same score it
doesn't matter
right but others you know that's it's
not the same case right
if it let's say it now if it flops like
it's like let's say it gets even in the
70s or anything like that and
people are not even playing it you know
past a month
because i don't they hate the
multiplayer the story sucked and
everything like that
then then that that is gonna be a huge
stain
on on halo and and xbox
and especially since like this is
supposed to be
your first you know uh your first first
party
game to drop i guess on the on the
series
on the on the new console right that's
gonna be really bad
and i think if there is
the next halo which is way far in the
future after infinite you have to do a
drastic change of what halo is
right gameplay wise you have to
drastically change it
and you might have to like just make
another date they have a whole bunch of
other studios now
something else has to become synonymous
with the xbox brand
at that point like you just use
something else not it can't be
master chief in halo no more yeah i got
plenty other games playing other studios
make make something else put something
else in the spotlight and
i think that if halo comes out and it's
a disappointment
i think if it's an average they're just
going to keep it moving there's going to
be another halo coming out
but i think if it's a disappointment i
think 343 is going to get drastic i mean
it's already going to get restructured
we've already seen it but i think that
there's going to be drastic restructures
i think they're going to do whatever
they can to keep the install base there
but i don't think any scenario hurts
microsoft to the point
where it's like a long-term effect
because
and the reason i say that is because
gamers are fickle
you know when obsidian drops the new
heat
and bethesda let's say starfield comes
out and it's good which you know i know
a lot of people here are very
skeptical of bethesda but the core
studio bethesda's always made good games
game of the year contenders almost every
time fallout 76 was made by another
studio it wasn't made by the core studio
bethesda
i feel like with the amount of studios
that they have and people be acting like
these studios made
like really bad games no they didn't
like they bought them for a reason now
there are some of them that's
that they need to prove themselves like
compulsion under labs
but for the most part the studios that
microsoft owns
have made nothing but 80 85 and 90 plus
games
and i feel like when they start getting
that machine going
sure people are gonna be like man i wish
halo would have been better but they're
not gonna
they're not gonna just not buy the next
elder scrolls they're not going to just
not
buy starfield they're not going to just
not buy whatever surprises doom
whatever the next wolfenstein like it's
like it's like we've always said for
years
you make good games gamers are coming it
doesn't matter
and at the end of the day as long as
they get that done
i feel like regardless how halo comes
out in june in november it's not going
to matter
uh but obviously if if it comes out
really bad in november
it's going to hurt the halo brand just
not necessarily
like destroy the xbox brand if that
makes sense to you
because i feel like the reason that they
bought these studios
is because they're tired of relying on
nothing but halo gears and forza
and they want to pass the torch steps
they know that their fans are tired of
that too
and to me i personally feel like
microsoft knows that
halo can't do it anymore and they're
using
hey uh they're using what's it called um
they they're using stuff like elder
scrolls they're using those games to
take the torch
yeah so that that's my thing but bg you
can go ahead and get up out of here i
know you uh you've got the stream man uh
i appreciate you coming on youtube about
the stream bg
yeah you're muted again yeah my bad what
you said
so what are you about to stream oh uh
i'm doing resident evil uh
eight village of shadows difficulty i
already beat it but i'm beating it again
so i know you said in your um your
where impression video if you were going
to go after the platinum
um in return are you are you have you
thought about that yet has that
have you made a decision yet no i think
i'm letting that one go at least for now
um yeah like i don't mind going after
platinums that
that are difficulty based but when it's
all chance based i'm like
i don't you know and i because i already
beat the game three times
yeah and i don't want to like keep be
beating it hoping
to like get the chance to run into the
right xenoglyphs and all that so i'm
letting that one go for right now
what was your fastest run so far oh man
probably like probably like eight hours
eight nine hours i think
okay i think yeah that's what's up man
congratulations on that too because most
people can't beat it one time without a
bad
problem
man he said it sounds like you're hating
on halo it should be
uh it should be good especially with how
hot xbox is doing now compared to last
gen it doesn't matter what xbox the
company is doing it matters
it matters how 343 is handling the brand
exactly
and as much as i do have faith that 343
can get where they need to be
they haven't shown me that they've done
it yet and i
hope in june they show me that they've
done it but you know let's get
bg definitely uh you know go go go
follow bg man where they can find you at
i'm sure everyone here knows you but uh
just broken games hdr twitter and
youtube
and i really enjoyed that jason uh
schreyer interview it was a good
interview
oh yeah i appreciate that i wonder if i
type in brooklyn skill tree would it
still take me to your channel
uh i don't know actually don't know i
wonder if i do that you know
shout out to um bg because you know when
people out here trying to think of
podcasts they literally probably got to
go to bg to figure out
if he already used it because the man
had so many podcasts with so many good
names
that he don't even use anymore didn't
you have a podcast with nothing but his
brooklyn skill tree
yeah the field of view park he people
had to remind me of that one with the
with all the hosts i didn't even
remember that though i was like i did
that yeah i remember
you you had a podcast that nothing but a
host of other podcasts on it
yeah i would sit there then you had that
father and son thing with kofi yeah the
father's
that was actually fun man i wish you
would bring that back that was actually
i was um that was classy bg right there
man
yeah i definitely all got time for all
that
oh you you gotta you got a real life job
and and married
mm-hmm all right but i appreciate you
coming by uh
uh bg we're gonna finish this last topic
uh i hope your stream goes good yeah
all right guys i'll
sunset overdrive two looks like it's
gonna happen
well i don't know if it's going to
happen but there's a good chance it's
gonna happen and
it's going to be on the playstation
platform
how bad does this look forte
it's going to happen because
playstation's like we got to find a way
to take our pile of flesh
from xbox and they go take it this way
it's um they know that their fans
wanted to have a sequel to this uh we
know that
um xamia wanted to make a sequel to this
game but
xbox didn't want to greenlit this game
for it to be made
so uh i think at this point insomniac
has shown
that they are willing to do whatever it
takes to get
games out when it comes to the type of
games that they make they're willing to
push the envelope they're willing to
go above and beyond to i mean if you
think about last generation alone
and this generation they have the most
games released
outside of uh like call of duty and
stuff
they release more games than almost
anybody but dude
so i think i think
i think sony's going to give them the
opportunity to make this game
do you think it's good i truly believe
they are do you think it's going to be
anytime soon
um what are they ratcheting clink is
probably
finishing up um
keep hearing about uh man anytime soon
maybe they want to go back into
think they're done with spider-man for a
while so i don't think they're going to
go back to that for a minute
i thought they're basically they're
probably i think that's going to be a
couple of years
i think the core of their studios i
think that their next game is going to
be spider-man 2. you think
you think so i think it might be it
could be
it could be or they could they could
throw a wrench and they could do sunset
overdrive too
he could like imagine how bad
that's gonna look when like an exclusive
that used to be out for xbox
is now the sequel is only exclusive for
playstation
5. uh do you think i think they do it
just what about
what about if they finally go back and
do the resistance games again
i think that's being outsourced i don't
think they're doing that yeah that's
true
it's true i mean probably yeah that's
true that's probably they'll probably
have somebody like blue point
do something like that i think that they
they would fun at sunset just for memes
like i would if i was listen man if i
was sony
and i knew i had an ip that a lot of
people on the other side
wanted i would do it especially
especially it could it fits their
character it fits
the playstation brand it fits that kind
of
wacky type gameplay that um people
expect to have
you know not doesn't take itself too
serious but it's really fun and really
addicting
um i think people will really enjoy that
and it wasn't it's not to say that xbox
people
didn't enjoy it i just think that game
was way too soon for the type of console
that xbox was promoting at the time you
know
back then it was the looter shooter box
still you know titanfall was all of the
rage you know call of duty was still
exclude not exclusive but we still had
the dlc
uh one month early access on xbox back
then halo was still
king of the kings and stuff for the most
part when it came they still could fight
it out with call of duty
so i think sunset was like an experiment
that now if xbox would release something
like that
would tur would go over really well
because i think they diversed their
player base a lot since 2013 2014
but when that game first came out it
just kind of fell on deaf ears and
is a lot of people played it but not
enough people played it
and uh xbox was in a completely
different head space with leadership
back then they really wasn't
supporting um the continuation of games
compared to like they're looking like
they're trying to do now
yeah i think when it comes to this game
i think sony knows that
it is a loved game and it's something
that they would support themselves
anyway
i don't you know people in the chat are
saying they think they're making
resistance i don't think that
uh if you remember this is a strong one
man
you remember sony said that their
multiplayer games chances are going to
go
to uh uh to pc2
so i don't think they're going to let
their first party work on a title that's
going to pc
i think they i think they rather
outsource that and probably take a
couple key developers from
uh over uh from from oh uh the um from
insomniac
and have them work on it with that team
that have the entire team of
of of insomniac make it because like
look
we get it people like resistance but you
know what sells better
ratchet and clink i bet you ratchet clay
sells better than
uh resistance you know what sounds
better spider-man
i'm i don't even know maybe sunset
wouldn't sell as much as as resistance i
don't know
i it's on playstation so i think we
can't really take the sales of xbox into
the consideration
but i feel like it makes more
business choice financially for them to
focus
on on another ratchet clank or make
spider-man 2
than for them to work on resistance
venom yeah
that could be a thing but make a venom i
mean you know you're
instead i mean if you want to put a
little bit more uh
time into the spider-man like make
people miss spider-man a little bit more
you know make that venom movie make a
midnight movie but game
so something like that i think insomniac
can make anything they
they truly want i think that's the the
you know that one thing that i will
always give slow mo credit for when he
made that video where he talked about
you know it's not naughty dog might be
the most accomplished team
but he thinks um xami is their most
talented
team because they're very diverse in the
way that they
go about making these games and and
they're not a one-trick pony they can
they can make different games and
different genres for different people
and that's what sony i think that's the
value that sony has with them
and i think sunset overdrive would just
be another
notch in that cap for them if they
actually did bring out a part two
and on top of that they just make a lot
of xbox people mad too let's be for real
and the reason i feel like that too
is because like look at all the studios
that's moved on
you know i'm pretty sure sucker punch
said they're working on another ghost
so it's not like they went back to
infamous um
naughty dog's definitely not going back
to jack and dexter they even
they even said that they're done with uh
with uh uncharted pretty much
clearly someone else probably make it
uncharted but but naughty dog's not
making uncharted but would it be
the same but but my point is to that is
all these studios have moved on to other
projects none of them has ever went back
to older projects
so why do we automatically think is
sonia gonna do it
yeah that's true like it seems like
sony's
sony's thing when it comes to these kind
of situations is we're outsourcing or
building another studio to make that
game we're not having
what some of our top tier talent make
this game that's true
no you're right but you know that's
pretty much the show man i appreciate
everyone coming by we had a strong of
like 130 in here
uh you know uh i'll be doing it again
next week hopefully
uh you know what we'll see the dude's
been kind of dry
forte man it's been kind of dry i can't
tell man you've been putting out videos
every other day
it's been dry man like you've been
you've been you've been digging on a
bear
it's not that i'm digging in anything
it's just like everything kind of to a
point
intrigues me so it's easy for me to make
videos on something just have a
conversation about a year
yeah so it's not nothing for me to find
something to talk about
uh it's it i want a structure it takes
longer than anything
but uh you know i definitely appreciate
him coming through here man uh
definitely uh forte where can they find
you what what's going on with that dps
yeah man um well first of all um
appreciate the invite to come over here
you know be a part of attic's world
attic show
on the iron lords networking podcast
channel
you know uh make sure you just make sure
you well you probably already
sub to these guys because you're already
here but uh appreciate you attic as
always but um
it's gaming forte everywhere youtube
twitter xbox live and playstation
uh check us out on dps podcast this
thursday
at 9 00 pm you know what go ahead go
give me one second you know
we won't end it with that real quick i
want to talk about this
real quick oh okay i'm gonna send you
this link
go ahead and pop this in your okay i
forgot all about this man i was gonna
talk about it
now i just want your ideal on
if you think any of this is true like
any of this let me find you
okay i'm sending it to your twitter uh
sorry about that you guys but i gotta
i gotta see if forte feels like this is
true man
because lord this is a pretty crazy
list like we got to talk about i forgot
you know what's funny i went over about
to end the show after you give
gave your shout outs and then i saw this
because it was there
and i'm just curious first of all i want
to make sure can everyone
see this list is it on the screen
it should be it definitely should be yes
it is on the screen
so let's talk about this list real quick
or do you are you on it i'm on the list
all right so
we have 20 21
obviously this is an easy thing to say
because
it's this year got age of empire four
death loop microsoft flight simulator
psychonauts
forza horizon 5 star filled halo
infinite
tell me which one of those you think is
real which one you think is fake
because i'm telling you right now some
of this list there's some real stuff and
there's some fake stuff
oh man are we talking about for 2021
yes let's start with 2021 um
i don't think wow well they say def loop
ps5 so we know that's coming
are they gonna are they actually gonna
is this what they're gonna show
i think this is what's coming out oh
this is okay this is what's just coming
out okay
um did they actually put a date on
psychonauts
i believe it is supposed to come out
this year yeah that's what i thought
yeah
so between forza and horizon i don't
one of those games ain't coming this
year yeah
so not for not forza horizon um
starfield and horizon one of those ain't
coming
one of those i think i don't think star
feels making it this year
i i i just think
that if we don't hear about it in the
next
month that game's not coming this year
you want my opinion on 2021 2021 age of
empire definitely ain't coming
you know hf empire is the kind of
release now is out on pc
do you think flight sim is going to
really come over i i think
i think these are really like what the
the studio itself still i don't think
it's necessarily about xbox
but oh yeah exactly so i think this
whole 2021's happening
i honestly do besides age of empire i
don't think that's coming to xbox
but as far as xbox i think this whole
list is coming out this
year well yeah def loot's coming
i just don't yeah agent empire i don't
think it's coming to the xbox
flight sim we already know it's coming
psychonauts got announced
like i said it's down to horizon and
starfield
and i probably have more faith in
horizon making this year
can i really truly think that they want
to have
a next-gen racer release uh winning a
year of the system
and starfield could probably get
possibly pushed into like
spring of next year but i
i i still think starfield from all of
the
from all of the stuff that's been talked
about and every
time phil spencer opens his mouth and
talks about bethesda he always talks
about starfield
so i think forza is a given
star feels the wild card but i just i
stand by the fact that they talk about
it too much not to come out this year
i think from from what from what i've
heard
through the grapevine i i think
starfield hey play that music man when
you say through the grapevine
starfield her uh forza horizon 5
halo infinite and flight simulator and
psychonauts all
definitely come out this year no doubt
on my mind so you know
we've we've went over 20 21 that was the
easy one the rest of this list is crazy
all right let's do 2022. what here's
fake find waldo what's fake
what's fake um
i don't we um
i don't think wolfenstein three is
coming next year project mara i don't
think it's coming next year either
because i think hellblade has a better
chance of coming next year
because it's made by the same freaking
people and their team ain't that big
um arcane's unannounced game could come
next year
but if it does it's going to get
announced this year avowed
oh man that's a
that's a tough one right there i just
see that being 2023
okay here's my opinion okay so if i had
to say
if i if someone put a gun to my head and
this is a forte
pick we know ghost wire
i believe hellblade 2 i think ghost wire
could come out on xbox next year i think
ghost wire could come out the beginning
of next year
and towards the end it's put on game
pass and comes out yeah yeah that's what
i'm saying
ghost wire is gonna come next i mean
well this is just showing the ps5
release ps5
first so ghostwire is coming
i think hellblade will be next year
uh arcane's game will get announced i
think that will come out next year
a vowel i still think is in the i think
when we saw
was the concept phase of it and i think
that game's going to be
like a mid 2023 game
so here here's my whoopee side three
that's a that's a that's a
i i don't know about that one either
here's my tape
all right yeah go ahead avods 2023
go go go 2023. okay
ghost wire that's probably coming out
next year i think hellblade 2 is 20 23.
i think wolfenstein three is a 2022 game
uh it's easier to make yes and they have
been working on it for a while it's been
confirmed
i don't know what arcane's working on
hopefully it's dishonored three that
would be
that would be lit and i know that that
team's been working for a while so that
definitely might come out next year
project mario that game don't exist to
me until i see more on it
so that's what i'm trying to say so you
so you don't think um
ninja theory is going to release the
game at all next year no i don't okay
could that cause that's the way i'm
operating on
if they're going to release anything
next year is going to be hellblade 2
because project mara i believe that
because obviously the pandemic prevents
large groups from being in buildings
yes uh especially at the beginning of it
and
just recently uh lifted restraints and
let people come back to the office that
worked for microsoft
it really hurt the mocapping areas
yeah a lot of hellblade's mocap so
that's why i feel like that that
i feel like hellblade's been pushed back
a lot um
let's go to 2023 because this is where
it really gets interesting
uh gears isn't coming out of 2023. uh
that's coming 2024. uh
doom 3 is going to release then every
while i don't even know what that game
is still
uh but more than likely it could release
in 2023 because that's two years from
now
um xenonx online unannounced project
what is that fable 2023
i i i see 2024.
i still think that they want to make
sure that game is 100 right
four's a motorsport i do think i think
fosun motorsport
has a better chance being in 2022 yes i
think in 2023
i think it's coming i think that's
coming next year
i don't i don't see a reason because we
saw forza motorsport
literally last year in engine running
so that game yeah i think that gives 20
22.
compulsion um what year did they release
we happy few was that 2018
yeah 18 i can so to be honest i could
see compulsion maybe coming out next 20
22
yeah maybe i don't know just depends on
what's going on there all right so let
me go over this
doom i think it's done i don't think
they're making another do oh you don't
think they're going to finish off the
dune slayer story the way i've been told
the expansion
that finished the doom okay because i
haven't played i haven't played
so guys they might do something else but
i feel like that team
uh that's some idea isn't it yes it is
yeah it's software i think they're doing
something else i don't know gear six i
think that's 20 25
yes i agree i don't think gears has come
out anytime
soon uh i feel like they're going to
make another game first
i don't know maybe they'll finish gears
before they do because it's been a rumor
for a long time they're working on a new
idea
i think they're gonna work i think
they're gonna they're starting and
they're gonna finish development on the
first on the
on the game that's gonna take a break
away from gears first
so i feel like doom it's like i said
doom gears
uh i don't feel like doom gears ever
wild
i think that's a 2024 game yeah um
because i don't know what they're
getting
zenimax online unannounced project i
think that could happen that year i
think 2023 is a good time for that
depends of what it is fables of 2024.
yeah uh forza is coming out in 2022.
compulsion is a good thing and josh
sorry unannounced project
uh i don't know about that that might be
2023. so that that's that's a solid
thing right there that could actually
happen
and keep in mind there's multiple
studios working for all we know this
this list could have two or three more
on each year
because there's multiple studios making
these games so uh
i think we've i think we've hit 2023
pretty good right you want to go to 2024
because this is where it gets even
crazier
so notice they just start saying
unannounced projects
games so okay so so okay
so in excel i think 2024 is actually
pretty good for them they had
in 2020 they released um they released
um
what's the name um i forget the name of
the game you played it um
wasteland three huh yeah wasteland three
they're
not making another wasteland type game
yeah then i think it's gonna be
something different so i do think
that end of 2024 it could slip to 2025
but i think it's a good chance that
their next game could come out 2024.
out of worst two um
oh man that was they just released the
latest dlc towards the end of the year
so that gives them four years um
if they i think that's 20 25 just
because i think they're going to be
even more ambitious with the game
especially with the market in the back
that microsoft is giving them
to be able to uh flesh out that game
even more
it could be a holiday 2024 game but it
might be an early
um uh uh like a february march game in
2025 but
i'm gonna stick with 2025 on that one
perfect dark i think that game needs to
release in 2024.
i at a certain part we didn't knew we
known
about this studio we known about them
longer than anything and perfect dark
just needs to come
if they can't get perfect dark out the
door by 2024 it's something really going
on uh
eva went in three um i don't even know
if they're making that game i don't even
think they're making that game
they might be they might be because that
is a successful game it is a it's a very
good franchise
i just don't know i haven't heard
anything about what that studio is but
you know what's crazy
the fact that he's openly coming out and
seeing
the outer worlds too he's openly coming
out and saying
evil within three but then arcane austin
he says unannounced project if you're
gonna go this
left you might as well put dishonored
three in that small
dishonored three up there right so
yeah so roundhouse studios unannounced
game
you could yeah what was what was that
last game
i think that's a new studio actually
yeah that's a new studio
i don't think they've made a game if
anything that i think that game could
come out
sooner than sooner yeah you would think
microsoft wanted to come out soon around
and studio it did double fine they're
releasing psychonauts um
this year so depending on the scale of
the game they want to go with 2024 might
be a good goal for them
and coalition i think their next game is
going to be
i think if anything their next game that
they're working on right now if it's um
to be really to be believed the game
that is going to be
um not gears of war
i think that's a good 2023 i think will
be
the year you would see that like 23 3 20
early 24
um and then but if they release the game
in 2024
you're not seeing gears six until 2026.
yeah okay here if they release if this
unannounced game project because we know
it says unannounced maybe it's not gears
of war
if that game comes out if this
unannounced game comes in 2024
kiss gears award goodbye for the rest of
this generation
you won't see it this year you won't it
will be a launch title for the next
generation
if they if they do this
all right so let let me go over this one
uh the exile i think that's 2025 uh
because
they have stated kind of that this isn't
going to be a small game like wasteland
it's going to be like a fallout level
kind of game yeah uh the outer worlds
too
that'd be crazy if we get a fallout
spiritual success forever
i mean hell at this point we might we
might get a fallout game from
from exile because they own the fallout
franchise right and then we get the
outer worlds two of 2024. i'm going off
home dogs list okay
right now in my mind this is facts
and then we get perfect dart we get to
even within three
what i think roundhouse studio they make
a lot of mobile games i think i don't
know
uh i don't know all of bethesda studios
like that double fight
i don't think double finds making these
stuff i don't think it's gonna take
four years to make double fines game
they don't really make
big massive games like that that's why i
said their gate could come out of 2023.
uh and then the coalition unannounced
project
i think that unannounced project someone
did say
you could put gears at 2025. they
already said they're not working on it
for a while
they they have smaller projects to help
them better understand the unreal and
five
and they're helping with halo and
another project i think that other
project is what he's referring to here
and i think that's coming up maybe next
year i don't think that's coming out
i think they've been working on that
game if he comes out in 2024 they're
definitely
not bringing gears in 2025. yeah and you
know
what i like about this is first off i
personally want double fine to make a
banjo kazooie that's me
that would be cool i think they're one
of the only studios besides writer that
can make a game like that
successfully we got a two dollar super
chat from uh jw is a shell
are the ps fans paying attention to this
list
i doubt it because this list is this
list is fire
it's a crazy list man so let's go on to
the
to the to the grand finale
all right oh lord elder scrolls six
this dude just put at the very end of
the list because he has
no idea when this game's coming out
i mean five what's that five years from
now
if starfield does release this year
if starfield releases it even if it
releases next year
2025 would be a
reasonable time to say that i think
we'll see it
right here about you should see by 2025
we'll see a game plan
yeah we'll see gameplay
microsoft can easily ramp up production
on this game by hiring more people
and it can come out in 2025 because they
have been working on it it's just it's a
smaller team it's not the same and it
also comes down to
it that's why i keep thinking with
bethesda it really just comes down to
this year if they can still do
what they normally do announce a game
not announce it show the game off and
then release it in the same year
in the middle of a pandemic then yeah
that game possibly will come at 2025
because they can talk about it show it
show game play and say do the fallout 4
and say
it's here all right stayed in a k3
do you think that's coming out in 2025
hell no it's coming to 2023
yes 2023 who i don't know what he was
smoking
but i wanted long time i showed that
they showed that
that teaser trailer like in 2019.
like this isn't playstation microsoft
for the most part here recently don't
announce a game and then like eight
years later it comes out like for the
most part
they're trying to stay away from that so
to say that state of decay 3
was announced in 2020 and it took one
two three four five years for that
sucker to come
out is a very far stretch i don't think
i think that's a 2023
2024 at all at most at most
yeah indiana jones where is it coming
uh machine games is making that so um
i i think 2025 is too far i think 2024
but keep in mind keep in mind we are
saying what else are they working on
well it's not even just that keep in
mind that
microsoft owns a lot of studios now
they're still making fur they're still
making game pass scenarios they're still
making
timed exclusives we know about the
kojima thing we know about
the the dragon thing and the which is
funny which none of that stuff's here
none of it's here but you ain't gonna go
into that so
uh when is that indiana movie i know
they were talking about making the
indiana jones movie
again did do we have any information on
that
i have no clue but because i would think
even knowing that the game's not going
to be tied to it because more likely it
won't be
they'll probably want to have like
within a year like how spider-man
and um and playstation had spider-man
lined up within a year of it coming out
so i think it's closer to whenever that
indiana movie indiana jones movie where
harrison ford gets tied in
i think within a year of that you're
going to see indiana jones release
what i was saying is like keep in mind
just because
like you know they might have a game
done but they're not going to put these
games too too close to each other
they're going to give some of them time
breathing
so games say they want to have a game
every quarter they want to have a game
recorder they don't want to have two
games every quarter no no they want to
go
every quarter so i feel like some of
these
like obviously if they don't make a doom
which someone in the chat that could
happen
so if they make a different type of doom
game they make gear six
they make um compulsions game
i feel like you start adding these up
that's more games than they can use in
one
like lit a year because they're still
having the the um
the i o interactive game they still have
the cyclone game
they still have these studios making
multiple projects
so i feel like logically they're going
to have to space them out so some of
these games might be literally done
and they have to push to the next year
to make it to the next year
to make sense yeah all right so uh
arcane's next project i think that's the
right uh yes it is that that could be
dishonored three
and this could be and this arcane austin
could be something else
i think what regardless what that arcane
game is it's not taking them five years
to make something
look look whoever made this list the god
of wars
don't take five years to make you know
what god of war took five years to make
you know why halo's taking so long to
make
they made an engine on top of the game
itself
games don't normally take this long to
make so
i see arcane's game coming out in 2024.
yeah i'm with you on that what about the
what about world's edge
that's those are turn base or or
strategy rts guys strategy rpgs yeah
so i could see that 2023 2024
no now we have another xenomax
media online unannounced game project
you know you know how easy that is you
know how easy it is just to keep
he just copy and paste that from 2012
you know
max is going to put out yeah he was
putting this in man this is
this is how this dude thought he put
this in here and this is he put it with
no bulletins anything he's like man this
list looks pretty pretty
i'm gonna put bulletins man i feel like
bull everyone likes bulletins they'll
take
more seriously so the most interesting
one on this list to me is
the last one 343 industries next project
notice this dude didn't say gear
halo 6 or something yeah next project
attic do we do whatever you need 343 is
going to be making anything other than a
halo game
i do i do you do what do you think
especially
if halo even even with halo having a
10-year plan
well see and this and this is still
winning five years of it
destiny i feel like when halo infinite
comes out the first three years is
is the most important to that 10-year
plan because they want to structure how
they want to have the game come out how
they want
the information rolled out i think by
three years
you think they gonna turn it over to a
subsidiary team
i think manage it i think all five of
these years
first off i do think 343 will probably
have a game
in 2024 2025 but i don't think it's
going to be halo i think it's going to
be a smaller title
with the halo type of budget but it's
not going to be on the massive scale
that halo is if that makes sense to you
so it's not going to be a halo game
no it's not i think it's going to be a
first-person shooter i don't disagree
with you i don't think that i i think
that all these studios should make
something different it's just
that that one of all of them just kind
of like
are we just throwing stuff against the
wall to see if it sticks
yes because that that that's always the
good thing to do man and it's like i
said i'm not clowning on the dude that
made this
i i actually i actually like that he
made it actually like you made it
because
when i saw this i wanted to make a whole
video on this thing
you should hey well you still can this
is this is the iron lore channel not the
um
not the addict's channel
but okay so one minute on each each year
so out of all this stuff here let's say
this list
is accurate let's say this is the divine
xbox list
what title on here makes you most
excited
ah man because at the end of the day i
don't feel like he's wrong
i just feel like he doesn't know what
years some of these games are coming he
just threw them in a random year
like i do feel like for the most part
these are the games that microsoft's
making besides all the
i might say stated to k3 man because
state of decay
they need to prove themselves and i feel
like state of decay
can be that game to do it if they make a
state of decay 3 and it capitalizes on
every corner you could think of
i think it will improve people's
perception on it is your streams is your
stream it's going off right now it says
excellent we're about to end it anyway i
apologize for that you guys that's why
i'm trying to finish this up
um i right now on my end it says it's
not buffering anymore but you know
we'll see we're about to end it anyway
uh and like i said
i think fable is the most important one
here because i think fabe